In this video, we're going to talk about
cross-sight scripting. You'll sometimes
see this abbreviated as XSS. The reason
we don't refer to this as CSS, which
would be cross-ite scripting, is because
we're already using that term for
cascading stylesheets. So, instead of
being confused between what CSS we're
referring to, cross- sight scripting
uses XSS. We originally called this
cross-sight scripting because there were
multiple sites involved due to browser
security issues. Cross-ite scripting
allowed one site to share information
with another site. Browsers today
restrict any type of information
exchange between different websites, but
we are still able to inject these
scripts using different mechanisms that
we'll discuss in this video. You'll also
find that there are a large number of
cross-sight scripting vulnerabilities
and we're constantly discovering new
vulnerabilities with different
applications. This type of attack takes
advantage of the trust that a user has
for a site. And as many of us have seen,
once you log into a website, you are
often trusted on that website for a
certain amount of time. This cross-ite
scripting attack takes advantage of that
trust to gain access to information that
might be on that third party website.
The script in cross-ite scripting is
commonly associated with JavaScript.
Although this is not the only type of
script that can take advantage of XSS,
but almost all browsers use JavaScript
and very few people have disabled
JavaScript from running inside of their
browser. So many websites are using
JavaScript to display information on the
screen that completely disabling
JavaScript is probably not a viable
option.
Here's a common implementation of
cross-ite scripting. We have you the
victim that has your browser on your
laptop. There's a trusted website that
you've probably already logged into. And
then there is the attacker that is going
to try to use cross-ite scripting to
gain access to this website that
normally they would not have access to.
First, the attacker needs to get this
malicious script to the victim. One very
easy way to get scripts sent to someone
is in their email inbox. So, our
attacker is going to send an email to
the victim and inside that email is a
link that is going to run that malicious
script. Once the user clicks that link,
the link is going to redirect the user
to this trusted website and it's going
to run a script on that trusted website.
The attacker is going to receive
information from that trusted website.
This might be information about the
user's account or this script might take
the user's session cookie, send that
session cookie to the attacker. And now
the attacker has the same access to that
website as the victim does.
Let's watch a cross-sight scripting
attack take place in real time. I am on
a website that is an intentionally
vulnerable application through Webgoat.
This is a shopping cart application. You
can see there's a few things in the
shopping cart and just like most
shopping carts, you provide a credit
card number and a three-digit access
code and you click purchase and it goes
through the process of purchasing
whatever you have in your cart. To get
to this point, we've had to log into
this website. We probably have an
account already in place and we might
even have our credit card information
already stored on this website. So now
that we've logged in, there is a level
of trust that we, the victim, have with
this website that we'd like to buy
things from. If the attacker knows this,
they can send us a malicious script
either through email or some other
method that will cause us to send this
information into this trusted website.
So the script that we're going to run is
the one that you see on the screen here.
You can see it has simply an alert. Now,
normally we would not be seeing an alert
on our screen, but for the purposes of
understanding what's happening behind
the scenes, I'm going to have this alert
message pop up on the screen. What would
normally happen is the information would
be sent directly to the attacker rather
than appearing on our screen. This is
going to show my session information and
it's going to provide my session cookie
on the screen. This is the cookie that
would normally be sent to the attacker
that they can then use to log in as if
they were us. So, let's copy this
information and we're going to put it
into any of these fields that we have on
this particular website. I'm going to
delete what's already in one of these
fields and I'm going to simply paste in
that entire script. And when I hit
enter, the script runs. And as you can
see, it says my session information
shows my session cookie. And now that
information could be in the hands of the
attacker. This would normally be sent to
the attacker. and they now would have
full access to this website as if they
were logged in with my account. So they
can purchase things, they can change
account information, and they might even
have access to my stored credit card
information.
Another type of cross-ite scripting
attack is one where the script is always
stored somewhere for people to access.
We refer to this as a persistent
cross-ite scripting attack or a stored
XSS attack. In a persistent attack, the
malicious script is stored on a public
web page and anyone visiting that web
page is going to run the script. It's
hard to direct this kind of attack
because you don't know who's going to
visit that particular web page. You
might be able to focus in on a certain
number of victims or it may just be
anyone who happens to visit that page.
Imagine on a social media site an
attacker putting this malicious script
and now anyone who visits that
particular page on social media now is
running that script inside of their
browser. One of my favorite cross-ite
scripting attacks was in 2017 where
Aaron Guzman found a vulnerability with
an automobile. Specifically, it was a
Subaru. When you log into the Subaru
website, each user gets a login token.
We saw an example of that in the cross-
sight scripting attack that we did. This
token, however, never expires. Once you
log in initially to the Subaru website,
you are always logged in on that
browser. This means if you could get the
session token for any user that is
logging in, you would have access to
their account indefinitely. This means
you might have access to change
someone's profile information. So, you
could change it from their email address
to your email address. And in the case
of our more modern automobiles, you
might be able to change things in the
car itself. For example, from this web
front end, you might be able to unlock
all of the doors to the car. And of
course, Aaron found that on the Subaru
website, there was this cross-ite
scripting vulnerability in the web front
end itself. Thankfully, this
vulnerability was not exploited by any
attackers and was resolved thanks to the
hard work from the research team.
One way to prevent a cross-ite scripting
attack is to prevent the script from
running at all. So, you should never
click links inside of an email message
or click any links on a web page that's
not trusted. You could also consider
disabling JavaScript, but we use
JavaScript so much on our modern
browsers that it might not be a very
useful way to browse the internet.
Instead, you might want to use
thirdparty utilities that are looking
for these type of exploits and will stop
them in real time instead of passing
that script to another website.
Sometimes these type of attacks are due
to a vulnerability in a browser or in an
application. So, keeping everything up
to date may allow you to stop this
problem before it even becomes an issue.
And ultimately, application developers
need to make sure that they validate all
of the inputs that are being put into
their application so that someone can't
run any type of script, malicious or
otherwise. By making sure the
application is secure, we can prevent
any type of cross-ite scripting attack
from occurring.